les deux
alors vous êtes ici tous les deux à
l'occasion des 20 ans de 37 2 le matin
voilà alors il ya un dvd édition
spéciale qu absolument génial avec dont
le disque 1 la version intégrale
remastérisée les bandes-annonces le
commentaire de jean jacques beineix le
disque de la version 86 un documentaire
37 de vingt ans après voilà bien un
problème béatrice blessés
non non tu vas tomber là non ça va
chauffer à debout tu préfères non si
c'est vrai oui
eh ben moi aussi je peux connaître
ça t'emmerde
alors toujours à l'occasion de cet
anniversaire au grand rex le 12 mai il
ya la nuit et master classes de jean
jacques beineix en présence de vous deux
plus jean hugues anglade alors une
discussion avec le public quoi ces
services le public peut vous interviewez
autant qu'il veut c'est ça oui dunga
veut dire jusqu'au bout de la nuit
jusqu'au bout de l'année comme on dit et
à la projection de la version intégrale
et il ya la projection de deux films de
vous qui sont introuvables en dvd la
lune dans le caniveau donc avec gérard
depardieu et nastassja kinski
et puis ip 5 avec yves montand olivier
martinez et géraldine pailhas voilà donc
c'est la grande nouba beineix dalle oui
mais il va falloir le faire ouais c'est
un peu fait un peu flipper quand même
ouais le grand rex est plutôt
rock'n'roll normalement donc là
tu veux rester debout alors ouais ouais
si je suis main sur le truc d'un thème
pas ça ba aujourd'hui je n'aime pas il
va chez drucker il est capable
c'est confortable chaud drucker mais à
part qu'on a les genoux dans le montant
mais bon pardon tu veux pas essayer
debout juste deux minutes pour voir si
tu veux tant que
c'est une sorte de liberté
prendre 7 2 donc 37 deux orgues 37,2
l'histoire de bettié d'orx est devenu un
film culte le film de noeux et il est
venu pour donner
pourquoi c'est devenu un film culte et
votre avis jean jacques tits c'est une
histoire d'amour c'est une grande
histoire d'amour
et là je suis assez à l'aise pour en
parler parce que c'est jean qui l'a
écrit moi j'ai rien que l'adaptateur et
elle a été incarnée par des gens qui
avaient une grâce
si on regarde betty betty c'est une
révolte et
les bêtises 20 ans aujourd'hui elles
sont encore plus révolté il y avait
quelque chose d'une de la modernité de
notre époque quand même temps il y avait
quelque chose qui a été c'était roméo et
juliette c'est une histoire qui se finit
c'est mal mais en même temps il vaut
mieux que ça finisse mal plutôt que de
vivre une vie médiocre et j'ai
l'impression que dans le monde entier il
ya des gens qui ont eu ce sentiment il
ya un jour des gens qui m'ont j'ai
compris pourquoi savent pourquoi ça
avait marché c'était en roumanie c'était
juste après ceausescu j'ai rencontré
deux jeunes qui ressemblait à betty et
orgue et m'ont remercié à la sortie mais
d'une manière tellement fort tellement
sincère que j'avais je leur ai dit mais
pourquoi ils m'ont dit vous savez pas ce
que c'est que graves dans le
totalitarisme
on peut même passer mais
voilà donc là vous nous avez raconté ni
une vraie histoire d'amour et c'est la
liberté s'affaiblit bernatoire ça doit
être ça
une explication béatrice au succès de ce
film et au fait que ce soit devenu un
film culte
peut-être parce que les deux acteurs est
inconnue les gens se sont identifiés
donc y croire quoi puis on est vachement
bon et beau temps donc
c'est plus cool c'est comme à la maison
je peux m'asseoir tu peut-être ça tu
peux t'allonger absolument absolument je
fais pas ça chez drucker non maintenant
je quitterai pas tout mettre non ce film
a révélé béatrice qui est devenu une
star suite à 37,2 alors vous aviez
débarqué à paris à l'âge de 14 ans en
1981 vous arriviez dumont vous cherchez
du travail
quoi j'allais chercher de travail mais
justement ce que j'allais chercher du
travail sans grande conviction
faut dire que faute de dormir la nuit
vous dernier le jour donc effectivement
c'était pas très facile pour trouver du
boulot mais vous étiez intimement
persuadé de votre bonne étoile une
voyante vous avez dit que vous alliez
lui arrive et que l avez raison cette
voyante à la vous avez dit quoi
exactement que je me marierai 20 ans et
que j'aurai un multi qui me ferait
connaître comme scène c'est ma manière
un jour vous rencontrez un mannequin sur
les champs elysées qui vous emmène dans
son agence et vous fait la couverture du
magazine photo en février 85 en lolita
des rues et le numéro tombe sous les
yeux de dominique besnehard qui vous
fait rencontrer jean jacques beineix
d'abord la rencontre avec besnehard
parce qu'il dit que vous êtes la femme
de sa vie dominique oui oui mais la
raison ça s'est passé comment votre
rencontre avec b il m'a appelé il a eu
méreau personnel par le magazine et
comme tous les gens qui font du cinéma
pense que tout le monde rêve de faire du
cinéma c'est peut-être vrai aujourd'hui
moi ce n'était pas le cas donc il n'a
pas été j'ai pas aimé sa manière de me
parler pas j'ai raccroché j'ai dit vas-y
tu me rappellera que tu seras posligne
tu te présenteras puis après m'a donné
un rendez-vous super loin à boulogne tu
patines pour prendre un taxi j'ai pas
envie dans le métro donc il est venu me
chercher
j'imagine oui pourquoi êtes-vous des pas
perdus cinéma à l'époque moi j'ai mis le
prince charles et gomez
j'étais amoureuse du principe du
sceptique vous voulez devenir reine
d'angleterre quoi ouais ouais gensse a
une autre idée ont marqué et la première
rencontre avec jean jacques s'est passé
comment la baie moi j'étais sûr
conservant son du rouge c'est sûr
c'était gagné ah ouais elle a un une
vista je me souviens d'avoir emmené
bouffer des sushis et les mets rien dit
bon ça va être difficile mais en même
temps c'était sûr que c'était elle non
il n'y avait pas de problème c'est le
casting le plus facile avant ça a été
difficile parce que j'ai quand même dû
faire un procès virer un producteur et
non c'est une erreur parce que on
voulait que je prenne une quelqu'un de
connu et moi je disais non je ris à
bonds à qui on voulait vous preniez il y
avait il à bella gianni des gens comme
ça mais je voulais une inconnue points
et on disait mais vous les élèves à
trouver quand votre inconnu je disais
2002 annoncé qu'on ne connaît pas voilà
elle est ouverte elle est là quelques
parts sociales bravo est statistiquement
voilà c'est demain ou et puis elle est
arrivée
vers c'est quand même énorme et j&j on
m'a donné une photo la photo où elle est
comme ça j'ai dit voyez cette photo
c'est la fiche du film je les dis avant
le tournage ouais il ya des trucs qui
sont écrits ses écrits ses réaligner
voilà c'est vraiment le jour et l'heure
pour voir c'était vraiment
les jo et leur alors ce film a eu
beaucoup de succès aux usa et dans le
monde entier d'ailleurs alors il était
nominé à l'oscar du meilleur film
étranger mais la scène de baise au
départ oui sage à 20 j'avais un copain
labaki était monteur il m'a dit ne fais
aucune espèce d'illusion trois minutes
de bèze pour commencer un film tu n'as
aucune chance j'ai assez vite compris
que je n'avais aucune chance et c'était
déjà pas mal d'avoir une domination
c'était moins bien d'être d'être appelé
par anthony quinn parce que il a dit mon
nom d'une telle façon que je pense que
personne n'a jamais su que j'étais venue
aux oscars que
jack
est alors le pire c'est que la veille il
était venu me trouver et il m'avait dit
bonjour je suis anthony kim je dis oui
jeu
et il m'a dit comment ça se paye nex aux
côtes
glock et le lendemain ouais trop j'étais
misérabiliste et ses théories
vous êtes devenu la sex-symbol des
années 80 vous êtes entré dans la
légende à travers un seul film
c'est énorme
normal non
ouais c'est
c'est dur après de de refaire un film
pareil non il ne faut pas essayer ouais
non moi même j'ai des problèmes après un
check up c'est pas évident de s'en
sortir
si c'était à refaire dans les 20 ans qui
sont écoulés depuis la sortie de ce film
qu'est ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
peut-être que je produirai pas mes films
et vous béatrice était à refaire un film
tout naze où je me suis trompé avec un
metteur en scène elle quel malade j'ai
fait une connerie mais c'est se
qualifier régis est même plus longue
ouais vous être vus tous les deux depuis
20 ans où se croisent régulièrement mais
pas beaucoup en a beaucoup c'est vrai
mais on a eu un tel truc famille du
cinéma mon cul non mais c'est sa cinéma
coups de feu en l'air fish après d'aller
faire du shopping avec le metteur en
scène ça m'intéresse pas quoi je n'avais
pas eu envie de refaire un film avec
elle
vous imaginez un peu c'est comme vivre
la plus grande histoire d'amour de sa
vie on revient pas c'est il faut il faut
réinventer quelque chose alors là c'est
vrai qu'on se revoie beaucoup
et
je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose qui a
changé les elle est encore plus belle et
plus forte qu'avant alors et puis elle
m'a dit qu'elle voulait faire du théâtre
à
ceux du patinage artistique oui et en
attend oui alors dit de nice
et et enghelab vous l'avez revu
quasiment pas on s'est revus pour la
première fois il ya un mois parce que là
cette promo pour faire des photos des
interviews ensemble où je suis mon
possible
et je disais ça il ya deux jours dans la
voiture je me suis rendu compte qu'on
n'est lié infiniment tous les trois pour
toujours de manière très bien sûr alors
béatrice êtes ce mois ci la rédactrice
en chef d'un magazine sa peine maximale
et vous dites au sujet de votre mari qui
est emprisonné pour pour 12 ans quand on
a trois quarts d'heure deux fois par
semaine pour se voir ce n'est que
l'essentiel mais je suis plus dans son
intimité et lui dans la mienne que des
couples qui vivent ensemble depuis 20
ans oui je pense vraiment d'abord c'est
pas le premier homme que j'ai dans ma
vie c'est la première fois où
il a vraiment sa place de mariée mois
des pouces je me sens plus protégés que
je n'ai jamais été mal gré dans la wiz
trop cher que la première fois vous avez
vraiment le sentiment d'être mariée
c'est avec un mec qui est en taule oui
parce que voilà il a trouvé sa plage et
toi la mienne évidemment c'est au style
sa place non sans jeu de mots d'un
couple et effectivement quand on a si
peu de temps être ensemble bon moi je me
souviens faire une séance de photo il ya
peu de temps où la photographe venait de
s'engueuler pendant trois quarts d'heure
avec son mari c'est que moi je n'ai que
ça donc c'est pas possible de cinq
années c'est pas possible j'ai
finalement
c'est oui quant aux trois quarts d'heure
ce que j'ai dit bien quoi ça c'est pas
que ces objets de bien mon bac à
l'essentiel tout le temps quoi donc
c'est ces gens ressort du parlement je
suis toujours super fatigué comme si
j'avais passé une journée inouïe
tellement à emotionnellement c'est il
est emprisonné aux arènes vous prenez le
train de voir monsieur
c'est l'amour c'est moche
vous dites les gens n'imaginent pas quel
point notre relation est la plus simple
la plus évident on est des gens les plus
simples et plus ouais vraiment on
imagine moins quelqu'un de super trash à
lui c'est la même manière quand tu
mettais mon ensemble on n'entendra plus
jamais parler d'eux personne mais quand
il va sortir de présenter deux vous
engueuler tous les jours non non non non
non non vu ce qu'on est en train de
vivre non c'est pas possible vous avez
d'attendre pendant 12 ans miss à votre
ami penn déjà on a une chance et puis ça
soigne un procès en appel donc ouais
pourquoi mais je prendrai le temps qu'il
faudra oui oui voici un il nous regarde
là vous croyez ouais je pense bonsoir
oui
et je laime fort s'ils savaient
absolument penser qu'il est innocent
vous toute façon je vous dis je peux pas
faire de commentaire vu que dans
quelques mois ils repassent devant les
assises donc ce sera un peu mal fini
ouais mais louis ii dit oui dans tous
les cas besner a été génial italie ou au
procès et il a dit en tout cas moi je
peux vous dire que quand il sortira de
prison suffirait du boulot mais c'est
vachement bien ouais il est génial vous
êtes prêt que la béatrice on va faire
une article you a review
vous pensez à quoi à quoi mon mari
puisque tu viennes montré d'accord quand
vous vous regardez dans la glace le
matin vous vous dites quoi ça va plutôt
pas mal ouais c'est vrai quand j'étais
petit je lui ressemble et acquis à
personne à moi en a déjà tant des deux
murs en main personne geris non vraiment
grave vois-tu belle histoire d'amour
c'est gwenaëlle way est ce que vous
seriez prête à tout quitter pour le
grand amour ah oui vraiment son amant
oui quand avez vous pleuré pour la
dernière fois
mon dernier parloir vous vous changeriez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique
pour lui dire quoi de plus négatif sur
vos rien j'ai pas envie de moi je sais
c'est un truc je ne fais jamais je ne
critique pas je ne sais pas remarqué
mais j'aimerais être comme ça des gens
font attention à vous défaut je vais pas
leur signaler
julia qui avez vous le plus envie
d'épater dans la vie mais mon mari
qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous
n'aviez plus que 24 heures à vivre j'ai
peut-être plus grand 1 90
vous irez le voir ouais mon me serais
pas rentré malheureusement elles sont
j'ai déjà pensé au suicide ou jamais
qu'est ce que la vie vous a appris
jusqu'à maintenant
mais moi j'ai juste l'impression je suis
né adultes je n'ai jamais été en fond je
n'ai pas eu l'impression oui mais la
seule passion je vis à vis et
d'apprendre on a tout à apprendre des
autres donc la seule chose qui
m'intéresse et les rapports humains
échanges donc j'ai oublié la question
tellement j'ai essayé de qu'est ce que
la vie vous a appris jusqu'à maintenant
que j'aime infiniment les gens
je comprends pas tout ce qui se passe je
comprends pas à quoi je vais encore des
interviews juste avant devrait peut-être
que vous êtes une extraterrestre non
chien au contraire juste super terrestre
est juste humaine et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus